Hôm qua 20 năm năm 2018, tại khu vực trên đối thục mỏ khá thác đã của công ty chế nghiệm vứa hạn tấn,
sát cầm đối tình thình hoa đã sử ra vụ sật lửa đáng in trọc.
Tông tin bàn đầu, thưa điểm sử ra vụ việc.
Các ông, loa văn thời, sinh năm 2020, tâm vi sấu.
Loa văn khuy, sinh năm 2020, tâm vi chính vàng viến văn ngày.
Sinh năm 2020, tâm vi tâm, cùng chú tại tình yên bái, khu, này là tình lợ cài.
Đăng ra đồng tại khu vực trên đối đá thị bất ngờ khu lực lơ nất, đá từ trên đối sạch lợ xuống.
Hau qua, bông người từ vong trên đường đi cấp kữ, 2 người chưa tin thấy.
Hẹn các lực lượng cứu nạn đáng đáng đối lực sử dụng nhiều phương tị,
mạnh móc trên dụng trong nghiệp vụ, phải là ai càm, mấy giò của người thằng ngoại để hình chương tiếp cận hiện chương.
Tình kiếm là nhân bị vụ lấp.